[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns in
unser club
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
auf jeden fall hier in unserer kleinen
süßen mai kraftfeld meine lieben freund
in der letzten folge bei der lieben
freunde haben wir ja das pferd leider
nicht mehr holen können aufgrund meiner
erkältung und er hört doch immer noch an
meiner stimme ich bin immer noch leicht
angeschlagen die sache ist allerdings
dass wir das heute tun werden allerdings
sehe die bereits dass ich mir gerade
erst mal drei banner gemacht habe das
wurde mir nämlich und vestas denn auch
dass wir das tun das vornehmlich und in
die kommentare geschrieben und zwar als
kleine erinnerung dass ich ja doch immer
nicht die ganzen
hinten an mal ein kleines campingzelt
angebracht habe von neuer einmal ganz
kurz und kreis drehen und rüber auf
unsere trauer insel ich muss mich auf
jeden fall auch noch einen neuen helm
machen wenn diamanten ist er kaputt
gegangen wir müssen demnächst auch
endlich mal wieder in die hölle denn ich
idiot habe meine kompletten loden stäbe
zu lohnen staub gemacht weil ich dachte
ich muss richtig viel vertrauen
ich werde nun auf jeden fall hier vorne
hier und hier auch noch die banner
platzieren dann haben wir das zelt hier
vorne jetzt auf jeden fall fertig hier
vorne mit unseren kleinen süßen teilchen
da müssen wir uns ein bisschen angeln
nochmal demnächst wir haben noch gar
nicht ehrlich gesagt so richtig unseren
angelplatz dort hinten genutzt um uns
richtig bücher zu handeln aber das
werden wir alles demnächst machen wären
allerdings gar nicht mehr so viele
folgen jetzt zur verfügung meine lieben
freunde von einer wenn irgendwelche
ideen habt was ich auf jeden fall noch
in den letzten 20 folgen nur noch in
diesem projekt machen soll dann schreibt
mir gerne in die kommentare spams alles
voll mit irgend welchen ideen zu müssen
nicht nur in welche sachen sagen die ich
bauen soll da hab ich zum beispiel der
nächsten folge war sehr geiles vor
diesen leuchtpol
diese schätze ich bin ich bin richtig in
love in meiner welt ich weiß nicht ob
staffel 2 genauso geil wird wie staffel
eins aber das werden wir dann ja sehen
die sache ist allerdings dass ich nicht
nur die drei männer machen wollte bevor
ich das pferd wurde sondern ich muss mir
auch noch eine neue leine machen
beziehungsweise macht man sich ja glaub
ich immer
weil einen wenn man sich die kräfte oder
wir brauchen auf jeden fall am ball und
vier von den aqua hier muss dann auch
noch der krach den tempel wieder hin wir
brauchen auf jeden fall vier fäden und
einem slum bei der kommt in die mitte
dann haben nämlich die leine und damit
können wir jetzt aufbauen habe ich den
laden dann hab ich denn so viele sagt
ach wir wollen hier in der höhle auch
noch ist aber auch egal ist ob meine
lieben freunde denn es soll heute ja
wirklich ums pferd gehen das möchte ich
mich heute auch holen und um auf das
thema von gerade noch mal ganz kurz
einzugehen wir müssen demnächst auf
jeden fall mal wieder in die hölle denn
ich brauche die lohnen stäbe für die
perlen um dann das ende zu finden das
wird nämlich auch und in die kommentare
geschrieben und zwar wurde der zahlreich
gefragt luca willst überhaupt noch ins
ende gehen willst du den ender drachen
besiegen also an alle die nicht wissen
was das ist es gibt in minecraft das
ziel das spielt durchzuspielen in dem
sinne dass man ins ende geht das ist die
dritte welt neben der normalen welt wo
ich mich gerade befinde
neben der hölle wo wir ja auch schon das
eine oder andere mal waren und auch das
eine oder andere mal leider gestorben
sind neben der hölle und der normalen
welt gibt es auf jeden fall auch noch
das ende und das ende kann man nur ganz
schwer finden da muss man nämlich
irgendwelche länder perlen werfen und
die gleiten dann irgendwohin und da ist
dann ein portal und da muss sondern rein
und dann ist ein ende drache der mega
schwer zu besiegen ist und das werde ich
vermutlich dann eh nicht hinkriegen habe
ich es zumindest versuchen also deswegen
müssen auf jeden fall noch in die hölle
und
deswegen müssen wir auf jeden fall im
nächsten mal den never gehen und uns ein
bisschen ausrüsten und dass sich auch
noch kurz sagen wollte denn ich war
wieder eine menge unterwegs in den
kommentaren mir wurde
geschrieben das in der letzten folge
habe ich ja versucht diamanten abzubauen
[Musik]
es hat nicht so gut geklappt mir wird
auf jeden fall geschrieben woran das
gelegen hat und zwar befinden sich die
diamanten immer in der süd ausrichtung
und die südausrichtung haben hier ja
hier denn die sonne steht gerade hier an
ihrem mittelpunkt und hier fordern wir
keine sollen deswegen ist das norden
deswegen müssen das team ist auf jeden
fall noch mal testen die sache ist
allerdings dass ich jetzt erst mal ganz
kurz meinen pferdchen hier wiederfinden
möchte ich weiß auch gar nicht ob ich
überhaupt schon hier angelegt habe das
letzte mal oder warum ich hier plötzlich
in irgendeiner wüste bin hier ist
[Musik]
ich weiß wir haben das pferde ziel aber
ich kann bei sowas wirklich nie nein
sagen
marvin eis das ist wie weit das auch
hier untergeht was soll man da unten ist
das wasser das ist wasser
[Musik]
das war doch kein wasser
jetzt bin ich hier wieder in der höhle
ich wollte einfach nur das pferd holen
ich wollte einfach nur die arbeit du
scheiß trägt fehler wie ich wollte nur
ganz kurz gucken und sagen hier und auch
schon wieder ans netz ich wollte ganz
kurz schauen lassen abgeht
und jetzt ist hier
wieder seine riesen höhlensystem
ich höre schon wieder das nächste
skelett
es wäre aber trotzdem sehr sehr sehr
sehr wild
wenn hier
[Musik]
ok alles easy wir müssen auch einfach
glaube ich mal ein bisschen fröhlicher
durch diese höhlen hier durchlaufen dann
wird das alles weniger furchteinflößend
wenn man sich einfach so sagt hey guck
mal das ist alles easy dass wir sind
alles meine freunde ich mir passiert mir
nicht die spinne greift bin ich an
dich auch so guck mal da kann man ja
wird durchlaufen kann das wasser das
braucht er kein mensch einmal ganz
platziert sagt ja ganz groß mein held
oder nämlich nicht mehr de schon mal
ganz gut das wasser zu es mir ganz kurz
eine karotte die habe ich mir mal an
perfekt einmal sack und pack dann
regeneriert sich auch schon das leben
und jetzt können wir ganz gediegen war
[Musik]
jetzt können wir ganz
leute
hier sind so viele herzen
wir sind so viele ärzte
und so viele wege
dann irgendwie nochmal weiterführen in
neue wege
und neue riesige arbeiten
von jeder dass es wieder eine richtige
skelette hier
aber warum ist denn hier vorne licht
[Musik]
was geht denn hier
sind ja unfassbar viele ärzte
ich
kann aber nicht ich muss mein pferd
holen ich bin auch gar nicht ausgerüstet
um jetzt hier richtig krawall zu machen
in der höhle ich habe ja nicht mal mehr
eine helm ich habe nicht meine glück
spitzhacke mit dabei auch kein platz zum
inventar von daher würde ich sagen wenn
ich euch mal eine ganz kurze time lab
sein wie ich hier den ausgang suche und
dann
hoffentlich auch mein pferd irgendwie
wieder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so da sind wir hier vorne wieder
angekommen ich weiß nicht mehr welches
pferd mainz war da stand ja hier vorne
rum da vorne sehen wir auch dass der
baum noch immer nicht ganz sich
abgetragen hat kann ich mir eben ganz
kurz gucken ob da irgendwelche setzlinge
sind oder irgendwelcher stocker schon
runter gefallen dann kann ich nämlich
wieder mitnehmen und vielleicht auch
meine trauer in situationen perfekt
nämlich absolut gar nichts hier vorne
mitfährt innendesign ich glaube das war
das hier oder wir hatten ihren komplett
braunes pferd ohne diese weißen flecken
von daher vielleicht wir uns jetzt ganz
einfach mal an mit kompletten voll
sprint und versuchen das mit dem
perfekt das was nicht vielleicht war es
das hier vorne ja dann können wir hier
auch
das salz gerade falsch aus das hier ist
auf jeden fall unser fertigen aus der
letzten episode ich dachte das wäre
komplett braun gewesen allerdings hat
doch so ein paar flecken drauf und jetzt
können wir anscheinend uns einfach
draufsetzen und ihr seht auch schon in
die richtung die ich gucke können wir
uns nun glaube ich bewegen und wenn ich
jetzt drücke sehen wir unser fährt kann
jetzt auch eine rüstung annehmen die
haben ja damals im nenner gefunden von
daher lockt
schneller geht das nicht er
wisse schon dass es ein bisschen
schneller gehen würde die sache ist
jetzt allerdings dass ich ja das pferd
irgendwie mit rüber aufs festland
kriegen muss und da habe ich mich auch
ein bisschen informiert und man kann
anscheinend das feld einfach an leinen
ich setze mich in mein brötchen und
fahre jetzt einfach losen das pferd
kommt anscheinend hinter mir her
unter euch
ist jetzt auch nicht so tierfreundlich
was wir dort veranstalten
euch der größte teil bis ich wieder zu
hause bin
[Musik]
wieder zu hause angekommen meine lieben
freunde ich werde mein brötchen jetzt
mal ganz ordnungsgerecht natürlich
selbstverständlich hier vorne abstellen
das pferd ist immer noch angeleint bei
mir von daher kann ich mich ja jetzt
theoretisch einfach nach hier oben
bewegen das pferd läuft elegant über die
schildkröten drüber und kommt dann auch
einfach kurz mit perfect schafft's das
nächst es wieder im wasser perfekte uns
einmal kurz die hoch
natürlich bleib da hab ich probiere es
jetzt einfach mal auf der seite hier
vorne dann gehe ich hier eben hoch und
versucht das pferd hier hoch zu kriegen
perfekt das hat auch geklappt und was
ich auch gelesen habe war dass ich das
pferd jetzt wohl einfach mit dem
rechtsklick hier daran festmachen kann
du bist ksc hingekommen um
eine karotte
perfekt geklappt ich wir brauchen für
das pferdchen allerdings nun auch noch
selbstverständlich die rüstung von der
ich gerade bereits gesprochen habe ich
weiß nicht ob ich die weggeschmissen
habe ich hatte ja da habe ich eine
goldene aber nach eisenach ist glaube
ich immer ein bisschen krasser nochmal
oder also eine rüstung ist ja auch
besser als gold rüstung bei dem spieler
von daher wird es beim pferd
wahrscheinlich auch der fall sein
deswegen packt man ihm immer die
einrüstung
da die sonne da vorne nun allerdings
auch schon hinter unserem los lukas
schild verschwindet und ins meer
eintaucht und das pferd hier und auch
richtig suite steht so schön angeleint
will ich an der stelle die heutige soll
jetzt auch beenden ich muss mal ganz
kurz im panel geben
ich gehe nämlich nicht pennen
in die kommentare geschrieben eine
challenge soll drei tage lang versuchen
die nacht durchzumachen das werden wir
sehen ob das was wird von daher starten
wir die nächste folge genau hier genau
zu der uhrzeit sonst mache ich ja oft
dass ich zu beginn einer folge dann noch
mal kurz schlafen gehe das tag ist und
so dass wir nicht in die nacht hinein
leben aber die challenge nämlich auf
jeden fall gerne an wir haben auf jeden
fall das geschafft was ich heute
schaffen wollte nämlich dort hinten auf
unserer trauer insel die bagger noch mal
hingegangen dann startet auch schon die
ersten skelette zu spawnen wir haben
unser fertigen geholt wo ihr gern mal in
die kommentare schreiben könnt wie ihr
das nennen würde
das waren wir nicht was sich nur noch
gerade ganz kurz sagen wollte war es
kommt mir die kommentare voll mit dingen
die ich in den letzten 20 folgen dieses
projekt jetzt noch machen soll und sagt
'natürlich ist wahrscheinlich ein daumen
hoch und video abonnieren kanal und
klickt auf die glocke wenn doch keiner
seite und ich werde jetzt mal ganz
schnell das video denn hier ist bauen
immer mehr monster und ich habe
kein bock auf negative bekanntschaften
[Musik]